this year I spent over 700 hours playing
Elden ring which is around 29 real world
days of game time so almost an entire
month of my year was spent inside the
lands between is that sad yeah a little
bit but do I regret it no not at all
this year has been one of the best years
of my life where I learned a lot about
content creation and what it really
means to be a YouTuber it's a learning
process just like most things in life
you pretty much just do your best and
try to improve your content
progressively if you make good content
then YouTube generally tends to push
that content it can take some time but
if you're consistent then I believe
anyone can be a YouTuber however I think
you have to genuinely be passionate
about the content you're making or you
won't be able to keep it going for too
long and I've been this way several
times I made valorant tip videos on
another Channel with up to 20 20 000
subscribers and just fell out of
Interest with it I was a rocket league
coach on Twitch all the way up to
getting partnered on there but I never
felt any long-term passion toward that
either and for a while after that I can
say that I was lost I knew I wanted to
create content but I could never figure
out what I would be passionate enough
with the only game that I played over
and over again was Dark Souls 3 my first
Souls game that I put thousands of hours
into but never once made content on the
furthest I'd go with it was streaming
myself speedrunning Dark Souls 3 but
with an audience devoted to Rocket
League coaching skull's game
speedrunning was not exactly what they
wanted to see so with nothing to make
content on I sort of just waited waited
for something to release that would
pique my interest and passion for
Content creation again and long story
short Elden Ring released and the rest
is history to say I was obsessed with
this game would be a complete
understatement my first playthrough
lasted about 60 hours and I didn't even
fight Melania or Moog during that
playthrough 150 hours later and several
New Game Plus runs under my belt I still
hadn't had enough of Eldon ring I
decided that I was going to try my best
to understand everything about this game
I read every item description started
word docs and Excel spreadsheets to help
connect everything in terms of lore
would I say I was successful at
understanding everything no not even a
little bit even now I can't say I fully
understand Elden Ring's lore I don't
even think that's possible which I
recently accepted but for a few months
earlier this year I was beyond
frustrated I had made some lore videos
that were doing really well for
basically a completely new channel but
of course for every Theory there was a
counter theory that I'd read in the
comments or watch a video of that
completely altered my own Theory and
sent me down a confusing rabbit hole
that constantly had me thinking that I
was just an idiot I felt like I wasn't
capable of understanding eldenring I
kept feeling like a failure in what I
tried to do every single day eventually
I decided to take a step back to take a
small break I found that comparing
myself to other amazing Elden ring
creators was making me worse at making
videos myself comparison is the thief of
Joy so I decided to stop doing it all
together I deleted Twitter I unfollowed
everyone on every platform and I stopped
watching Elden Ring videos on YouTube
now I didn't do this because I disliked
what other creators were making I did
this so I could be the best version of
myself I wish I didn't have to do this
and eventually hopefully I won't but for
now this has worked for me and has
helped me create a narrative with
eldenring that I understand and I enjoy
because I believe this is how the game
was designed for each individual player
to have a different experience playing
that they will come out with different
understandings and beliefs in Elden
Ring's lore and obviously there's a lot
of factuals that isn't theoretical in
the game but the deeper meaning to
pretty much everything is it reminds me
of real life in a lot of ways or maybe
I've just been playing too much Elder
ring this year I don't know you can be
the judge of that Elden ring consumed my
entire life this year I live streamed
100 playthrough where we did everything
in the entire game every boss questline
everything following a spreadsheet we
beat the game with the randomizer
enabled that gave us that amazing sense
of Discovery like when the game first
came out it was so much fun to wonder
what was around every corner I tried to
beat the game as fast as I could all in
one stream and spent four of the total
eight hours on malacath alone whatever
it was I was struggling so hard with him
and it was awesome to have hundreds of
people in the chat room cheer me on this
was one of the best moments of the Year
for me when I finally beat malekith
during this quote-unquote speed run
we went back and played all the other
Souls games except for Dark Souls 2 and
Demon Souls which I plan on doing in the
New Year we spent five hours on Orphan
of costs and Demon of hatred during
those playthroughs attempting these
bosses over and over again never giving
up with yet again hundreds of people in
the chat room rooting for me
oh my God it happened
oh my God
[Music]
it's just an amazing feeling that I feel
like I have to say thank you to each and
every one of you who has watched my
videos tuned into the live streams and a
massive thank you to the Eldon ring and
souls Community for giving me this
amazing opportunity this year eldering
has changed my life and if you want an
even deeper look back at what this game
has done for me in my life check out the
video linked here as it goes a bit
deeper with the entire story it's kind
of a sad story it's kind of depressing
so if you don't want to hear that don't
tune into it but if you're curious you
can go watch it when I say Elden ring
saved my life I truly mean it I was lost
and I feel like I've learned so many
lessons this year because of Elden ring
that I feel like a new better person
because of it all I want to do is make
good content for you all to enjoy and
that's what I plan to do all of next
year Elden ring has actually made me
start studying cinematography so I can
continue to make my videos better and
better every time I release a new video
I had planned on releasing a video
series called the fallen leaves that was
almost too ambitious of a project to do
completely on my own it was going to be
a literal TV show that would depict a
character named Rick voice acted by
myself going through the lands between
two hopefully better illustrate the lore
of Elden ring in a cinematic Hollywood
style I got the first episode done and
unfortunately the power went out in my
house while I had my computer on with my
editing software open as well this
caused all of my footage to look and
sound distorted and after days of
researching and attempting to fix this
issue nothing worked and I eventually
gave up this destroyed my motivation as
an entire month of work was just gone in
an instant after some time I told myself
that this was just another challenge
that I needed to overcome to better
myself as a person and as a Creator
eventually I released my first cinematic
Story video of Latina's Quest
and I could not be more proud of how
this video turned out it is my favorite
video I have ever made and I have Elden
ring to thank for it every inch of Elden
ring just looks like it was ripped out
of a painting So creating cinematic
shots to better showcase how beautiful
this game truly is just makes me happy
it is so much fun and I don't see myself
doing anything else for the foreseeable
future I had been waiting for a game
like Elder ring to come out my entire
life for me it is the perfect game that
I was ecstatic to learn one game of the
year for 2022. please please please
please please please come of the Year
winner is
elderly yes dude yes bro yes
yes it taught me a ton of lessons that
their previous games taught me as well
don't give up don't you dare go Hollow
on me never stop attempting to be the
best version of yourself failures are
just lessons on your road to success and
winners are just losers who never
stopped trying this might sound like the
basic motivation quotes that we see on
Tick Tock or whatever but it is true
just never stop trying and you will
eventually succeed it's like the story
of let me solo her who honestly is my
favorite story and person that came out
of this year he failed so many times
against Melania that when he eventually
succeeded he took his Newfound skill
against Melania to help others beat her
he just let you sit back and watch what
hard work and determination looks like
when you just don't give up I can't
think of a story of a player who
encompasses the entire lesson of all the
souls games more than let me solo her
eldering was like the only thing people
were talking about four months at the
beginning of this year it took over the
world and made me so proud to see a
Souls game finally get the mainstream
attention it deserves because while all
the pass games were popular of course it
was still a niche that didn't really
reach everybody like Eldon ring did this
game's impact on the gaming world was so
massive that I don't think anyone can
argue that it's the best game that came
out this year and honestly the best
creative Masterpiece that has come out
since Skyrim and maybe I'm biased
because this game changed my life but I
don't think it matters I know this game
has had a major impact on millions of
players around the world and now so many
more players have gone back and played
all the pass games and have found a
newfound appreciation for the best games
that have ever been released I've had so
many friends of mine who never
understood the appeal to a from software
game play Elden ring and then go back
and play all of the past games and have
favorites other than Elden ring that
right there tells the whole story for me
that Elden ring was designed to appeal
to a mass audience but it didn't have to
lose its entire identity to appeal to
that new audience from software has
consistently released good game after
good game and they're honestly one of
the last developers that I trust to do
that they have taught me so many life
lessons that I'm starting to consider
Miyazaki my second dad okay maybe not
that deep but you get what I mean I
appreciate Eldon ring so much I
appreciate everyone who wants to watch
my content from the bottom of my heart I
have all of you to thank for such an
amazing year and I have Elder ring to
thank for teaching me such valuable
lessons that have made me a better
person and a better Creator from the
time I'm recording this where only a few
hundred subscribers away from a hundred
thousand and I think we'll be able to
hit that by the new year which was my
goal from the start but this is just the
beginning for this channel as it's been
confirmed by from software that there's
much more that they want to do with
Elden ring so I'll be here ready to
constantly improve my content to
Showcase what an amazing game Elden ring
is thank you eldenring and thank you all
for watching this past year we have so
much more to do there's so much more
planned and so I hope you're ready to
experience it all with me as well have a
happy holidays an amazing New Year and
I'll see each and every one of you in
the lands between in 2023 take care